[Applause]
all right man
let's talk about the bubble okay it's
been a minute since
since there's been some good stories for
us to talk about in the sports world but
now i think we got one
there's something very interesting
that's happening with the bubble and i
wonder if it's happening to you guys
uh both in this room and everybody at
home listening
i could not give a [ __ ] about the nba
right now
i'm a long time nba fan i love i was a
seasoned
ticket holder for the new york knicks
i'm as invested as you can be
in the sport of basketball i would play
twice a week
in leagues i love basketball in love
with the game i haven't watched a full
nba game i could care less about
watching it
now at first i was like nah this is
probably just because it's not part of
my schedule and i'll get into it etc
that's not true i watch mma every
saturday almost it seems like there's a
fight on and i'll pop in i'll watch some
of the fight
why the [ __ ] am i not watching
the nba right now you know what it is
for me oh
are you watching i'm not watching as
much whenever i watch it i enjoy it but
this is what i've always noticed about
myself with sports so
i can't do low stakes sports
mma always high stakes you're fighting
once every few months
this is a big [ __ ] deal if i lose
this match nba you got these tune-up
games
that's great for the 910 seed and that
i'm interested in the 8-9 seat i mean
you can get in that plan tournament
these guys are fighting for their season
everybody else is just tuning up
and the highlights are fun as [ __ ] and
whenever i see these these last second
finishes it seems
exhilarating the moments i've seen have
been fun because it's like
it's just the game no other [ __ ] but
i can't do low stakes sports i'm the
massive football fan
i can't watch two teams with nothing to
play for we're playing for no re i can't
give a [ __ ]
i need space you hit it i think you hit
it i think maybe one
thing is the time the games are on
they're a lot
earlier now and you tend to have
be at studio during the time games and
mostly oh [ __ ] i never even considered
we're here because it's like
80 hours a week i've been noticing when
a game
is on and i happen to be home i'll
actually watch interesting
but it's really just most of the time
we're here scheduling yeah so okay
so scheduling weekend i was watching a
little bit just because i was
able to watch okay so scheduling i think
is a great point stakes i think is
another great point yeah
i was talking to some of my guys at the
nba and i was like you guys aren't doing
a good enough job
of creating stakes yeah like what do you
mean i go
this play in tournament the average
person who's not like a fan fan doesn't
even understand that these games are
valuable yeah
you haven't built in like i found out
that just
yesterday i think when dame lillard
dropped 50
he kicked the pelicans and
someone else out of the playoffs i
forget this is how detached i am yeah so
we kicked two teams out of playoffs with
that
victory why is that not being marketed
all over social why why is they are
these are high stakes
this is the end of someone's season
you're off to cancun yeah
you need to let people know and i think
what's going on
is my assumption is they're like yo once
we have sports back on tv
everybody's going to be obsessed they're
just going to watch it we don't need to
do nothing
[Music]
we have found other things to take up
our time
it's not like sports left and there's
this gap in our schedule we found other
things to fill that gap
we're watching a new series we're like
me and my girl watching all the james
bonds
in order of how good they are right
there's things that we're gonna find to
do you gotta
earn our [ __ ] time again make this
interesting with me when you said the
thing about mma and how always have high
stakes
yeah there is no meaningless fight no
every fight
matters your life is on the line every
fight so i could watch your life is
online
i can't watch guys playing a [ __ ]
pickup game basically when we watched
the mma fight in uh kansas city there
was somebody who was literally like man
i
we we lost our house we're like in
between homes we're moving like he
needed this
to keep his not only are you fighting
fighters feed his family like he's
crying after he wins
just some regular ass undercard match it
meant so much to this guy there's so
much stakes
damn lillard i want to see this
[ __ ] has put stakes on it
he's out here beefing with other players
he's fighting for the playoffs like
period that's the thing 51 he's going at
it even if
even putting up 50 and even like the
fight i'm like i'm seeing the perfect
recipe for an interesting nba season
and i'm just not plugged in like when i
see like dame lillard's
sister go at paul george and go
at patrick beverly online like it was
hilarious
damn was going on too i didn't even see
the sister oh yeah the sister got in on
it and then like
paul george's wife got in on it with
this i mean like it's all the hijinks
you need for an exciting season
but it doesn't have the stakes yet and i
was telling my guys i was like
when the playoffs hit i'm gonna be in
yeah
but y'all are [ __ ] up right now and
this is actually an important time
because this is where we get the ball
rolling for the playoffs yeah
let me lock into a team my team ain't
there so i usually lock in you know why
it's even lower stakes
and this is i've looked at this as like
it's just for them to warm up their
bodies it's like an extended pre-season
yes
seating doesn't really mean [ __ ] aside
from who you play home court advantage
there is no such thing as important
so like the only reason i want the one
seed is because it would be an easier
eighth seed matchup maybe
who do i match up with better yeah
that's it home court
meant something you wouldn't think it
but then whenever you get to a game
seven
that's the decision it means a lot of
[ __ ] it means a lot
now it's yeah we're all playing in
orlando the only one's got
home court is austin rivers he grew up
here that's it
yeah talking about austin rivers this is
really interesting he dropped
crazy he dropped like 40. was it 37. he
dropped he started 37 last night
i don't know what it was i'm guessing so
there's another player also who usually
he does yeah tj warren there's a few
guys that are playing exceptional
basketball and i'm sure it's not just
them but those are the names
he dropped 41 right so tj warren's been
bawling out of his ass
and i'm like why is it that certain
players are all the sudden
hooping i'm trying to figure that out
too i think i have
an idea i think there are two things one
is going to seem silly but bear with me
yes
i understand these guys are
professionals and it shouldn't matter at
this level but
bear with me i think the fact
that they're playing on a court that
just has a black
background that's pretty close to where
the backboard is
helps shooters if you're a shooter
and you're shooting at a glass backboard
when there's an entire arena behind it
it can throw off your depth perception a
bit like whenever i play in big open gym
remember we go like a basketball city or
that [ __ ] down there to play like
i hate shooting in those gyms there's
just so much
more room it's hard to like calculate
everything when you're playing
in like the half court somewhere that
has like a wall behind it or there's
something else or even like the
non-glass back i know this sounds so
silly
but i do think it helps shooters i bet
if they calculate shooting percentages
i bet you players are shooting better at
a higher percentage now because of
the background in which they're shooting
against that's number one number two
i think the players that get nervous
because of the fans i was just thinking
that yeah i think the players get
nervous because of the fans
they get caught up in the hoopla that
are thrown off by people booing them or
thrown off by massive cheers
and their [ __ ] get tight i think
those players
are having the time of their [ __ ]
lives just open gym it's open gym
the black background i don't buy into as
much because you play 82 games a year
so you play with that death all the time
like if you
you're playing what once a week at open
gym yeah if you played 82 times a year i
think you'd be like all right
these are the best shooters in the world
i know it sounds silly but there's
something about
like you know when you're at like a high
school gym you're at like the practice
facility a lot of these practical
facilities it's just like back back
board and then a couple more feet and
then there's the wall
with like those blue padding yeah i just
think there's something about
depth perception that plays into it who
knows i can believe confidence i can
believe getting out of my head because
it's like ah this is just an open gym
we're just it's just a run right no big
deal let's go
right i can believe that and maybe tj
warren kills it in practice
i'd be interested to know if he's like
pacer's practice normally he's just
tearing it up and then games he tightens
up a bit
maybe because i can see your depth thing
because they most of the time the
practice facilities are at smaller gyms
exactly if you're practicing shots in a
gym that size
yo that's another thing nobody practices
shooting
in the arena you always practice on
something with a closed backboard
backward close to a straight back wall
yeah you don't
shoot into the void like you do in
arenas because a
practice facility can't be on the same
place sometimes you got a hockey team
playing there you got the [ __ ] circus
in town there's tons of other things
i know it sounds absurd but i do think
that there's an advantage to it
and i think the fact that there are the
no fans there that could be booing
or even getting you hyped up or even
creating those situations where your
anxiety could affect your play
that again i believe i was also thinking
like i'm sure these
aau tournaments got not crazy numbers
not thousands of people but like
you're used to playing where you're
shooting and you're just seeing people
behind you
maybe it's a much smaller thing but
they've been doing this for decades at
this point
so but i can definitely believe yo it's
just i'm free here
there's no people [ __ ] booing like
you said there's no lights it's just
and it's interesting because who knows
how long we'll be in this you know the
election could come around and all of a
sudden corona could just go away because
that's
how things happen often right times but
if
corona is around for the next few years
and this is what basketball looks like
you could see some stars come out of the
bubble that would never have made
real money playing basketball tj warren
could get a massive contract yeah
because he's a bubble star
then take him out the bubble it could be
tough right
or he kills it in the bubble and then
builds that confidence yeah you get so
confident in the bubbles like i can't
play
i can do this who gives a [ __ ] what the
fans are doing i'm going at lebron every
night i'm going at devon booker i'm
going at all these guys i'm putting up
buckets
yeah let's go
you